welcome to the program we begin with the
breaking news that Russia has halted its
participation in the Black Sea grain
deal it was due to expire on Monday
evening
or Moscow says its conditions for an
extension have not been fulfilled but it
says it will immediately return to the
agreement once its conditions are met
the deal was brokered by the U.N and
turkey nearly a year ago and aimed at
helping preventing people going hungry
around the world Tokyo's president
Bishop erdogan says his government will
begin talks with Russia aimed at
continuing the deal
the announcement came hours after a
series of explosions on the Kurt bridge
that links Crimea and Russia the Kremlin
has blamed Ukraine but says there's no
connection to the cancellation of the
grain deal
well let's speak to Julia shop of Oliver
whose life for us in Moscow a newly uh
Moscow saying it will not renew its
commitment to this deal until its
demands are met what does it mean by
those demands
yeah that's correct but first no doubt
their attacks on the Crimean Bridge or
the courage Bridge as you say uh have
affected of course Russia's position on
the deal but even before Russia was
against its extension now according to
kremlin's spokesperson Dimitri beskov
the agreements on the green deal were
terminated and the deal was stopped not
just suspended but stopped meaning that
Russia won't allow Ukraine to export
grain from its ports and navigate safe
Passage through the Black Sea to Turkey
but at the same time again piskov said
Russia would immediately return to the
deal as soon as all the agreements and
Russia's requirements were fulfilled the
requirements were to reconnect Russell
horse Bank to Swift payment system than
the work of the Italian adieza ammonia
pipeline was also it wasn't resumed and
in June it was blown up in the in the
territory controlled by Key of blood
low-income countries received only 10
percent of corn and just 40 of wheat
most of the produce was sent to
developed countries so basically that
was one of the requirements not
fulfilled according to Russia so the
foreign Ministry spokeswoman Maria
Zahara also said that Russia has
officially notified turkey Ukraine and
the U.N on his decision not to extend
the grain deal and who also heard the
reaction from the president of the
Russian grain Union as saying that the
suspension of the grain deal will have a
positive impact on the Russian grain
market it does not need to be extended
so and now we hear from Turkish
president erdogan of course that the
grain deal is now part of History
and Julia the Kremlin saying that this
decision has nothing to do with the
alleged attack on the Kurt Bridge so
what is the Kremlin saying about that
incident
well but apart from the Kremlin there
are many unlits who say actually that it
will impact the decision but according
to Pesco the Kremlin knows who is behind
the terrorist attack on the Crimean
Bridge immediately blaming the key of A
regime that's according to peskov of
course and he also said that Putin will
hold a meeting on the situation with the
coach Bridge later in the evening and he
will listen to to some official reports
from his subordinates and
obviously they will report the situation
from the support uh because also said
that according to officials the railway
part of the of the courage Bridge has
been fully opened while the ferry
service will be launched soon as
everything is ready for that and the
authorities are still assessing the
damage at the moment
all right me thanks for that Julia live
in Moscow
well papa felger is a defensive military
analyst he says Russia's been planning
on terminating the grain deal for some
time but continued talks between
President Putin and Turkish president
erdogan had kept the deal alive
there were different from the problems
that Russia was complaining about it's
about uh Insurance of the uh these
Russian green exports because Russia
exports more actually grain than Ukraine
and also there were complaints about the
banking that money is for the Russian
grain is being delayed and that Russia
was demanding that one of the big
state-owned Banks Russell house bank
would get a renewed Swift
access which was uh since this bank has
is under sanctions doesn't have access
to Swift and the Russia says it should
have it there were Alternatives coming
from the West that maybe Russell was
Banco creates some kind of uh affiliate
and then this is affiliate will get the
Swift
connection
but that was being rejected by Russia so
most of Russia was saying that it might
terminate the grain deals for some time
but each time there were negotiations
between President Vladimir Putin and
Turkish president erdogan and the deal
was
continued though many in Russia were
saying it should be terminated months
ago so erdogan is going to be unhappy
and that's important for Russian for
Putin because that their relationship
with turkey is very important for Russia
there could be serious ramifications
or north of Crimea Ukraine's
counter-offensive continues in the east
of the country assabeg joins us now from
sevillesque that's near buckmouth and
Assad what's the latest in the East
Where You Are
well the fighting has been continuing
and with the ukrainians admitting that
different lines remain the same they say
that making small gains but at the same
time they have admitted that the
Russians are making advances in the
direction of kopiansk where the
ukrainians now say they are on the
defensive now if I could just show you
where I am right now behind me you can
see the artillery Jewel taking place if
my cameraman right it zooms in now
that's been going on for the last few
hours and you should be able to see the
smoke rising from
from where we are and you may also hear
some loud bangs those other artillery
guns uh firing and in the last step it's
really picked really picked up uh that
better than we believe uh what we see
there is uh near yampin and Tusk to the
north of us where Russia has been
claiming that they've been making some
ground now last night Harkey was hit we
understand there were casualties there
but really the the counter-offensive is
continuing but at the same time those
those front lines remain the same and in
some cases as the ukrainians admit the
Ukraine is on the defensive and Russia
is making some gains
and I said I understand you've been able
to get actually inside the town of
siversk that of course is south of the
hugely contested town of bakmud would
have been able to gauge there
well every single building is damaged
it's either burnt out the windows
smashed shrapnel holes in the walls
there's very few people left in that
town and the few that we spoke to say
that they hardly come outside they spend
their nights in the basement there's no
electricity there's no water they're
completely dependent on age that comes
in to that town and whilst we were there
the shelling began the Russians started
targeting Ukrainian positions but at the
same time when we spoke to people they
say the time gets hit every single day
and then we had to leave because then we
heard Small Arms fire now when you hear
that you understand that the ukrainians
have spotted a drone and they're trying
to shoot it down and that becomes very
dangerous not only for the ukrainians
but also the civilians that are there
and also us so we had to leave but that
town is just south of Bahamut where the
ukrainians say that they are firing on
enemy positions and the enemy the
Russians are firing back at ukrainians
the ukrainians say they have made some
small gains to the on the southern
but again there's no real change now we
have been hearing about this Ukrainian
counter-offensive but in reality the
Russians are not only holding their
positions now they're also pushing back
and trying to advance and trying to
break through those Ukrainian front
lines so that battle is ongoing not only
in subversing them backwards but right
behind me uh in the direction of yam
pilentursk
with a picture of the battle in eastern
Ukraine Assad Bank many thanks